good evening and welcome to this
performance governance and audit
committee meeting on Thursday the 19th
of January 2023 my name is cancer stamp
and I'll be chairing this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are given
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished please
reference a page and paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
members can I remind you that if you are
late attending this meeting obviously in
future because if you're late you won't
be hearing it you speak to the chairman
at the earliest opportunity for it to be
noted member can I always can I also
request that officers attend PG and a
meetings in person who are representing
speaking on reports and all the and the
agenda items for all future meetings
offices who aren't present have the
agreement of the chairman to present
remotely
for future meetings all new items will
be added to the agenda follow for future
meetings members all a new item will be
added to the agenda following minutes of
the last meeting
it is matter arising from the minutes
this will enable the committee to work
smarter bringing all actions identified
from previous meetings to identify how
long the item has been at risk what has
and is being done with dates Etc the
clerk burner will monitor this for the
committee and produce it for members
information I would like to thank
everybody I and I certainly see this is
the way forward
I know my cancer fluke is looking
perplexed but it will come into its own
at the next committee meeting
No Agenda item two members apologies for
absence can I have your apologies any
apologies for absence burner
[Music]
thank you minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 17th of November
2022 found on pages five to eight are
approved as a true and accurate record I
so move do I have a seconder for that
motion councilor Fleming
uh if member any members wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy they need to
indicate that they wish to speak members
no agreed by sent members agreed thank
you that's agreed burner Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuni
interests other registerable interests
and non-regitable interests relating to
business items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
gender item five members public
participation I can advise that we have
not received any submission from members
of the public
right let's move on to the business
agenda item six audit progress reports
we move to agenda item six found on
pages 9 to 14.
um I'd welcome Mr Leslie and ask him to
present the reports please
given the announcements over the past
months it's timely for an update to come
to members this report will cover the
order of the accounts audit fees and the
future external Auditors as well section
three of the report provides details of
the challenges facing the audit sector
particularly around Staffing and
additional audit requirements it shows
that for 2021 only nine percent of
audits were completed by the deadline
Sun councils also have audits from 1920
outstanding to given the scale of the
challenges for 2021 despite challenging
circumstances the council did publish
its unaudited accounts by the deadline
due to the pressures mentioned the audit
the accounts is still ongoing the
Auditors have been engaging with the
council and are commencing the audit
again and have indeed started
um last week as well to pick up some of
the some of the outstanding work uh with
a view to completing their field work at
the end of this month uh with a audit
review taking place in in January and an
intention to sign off towards the end of
March April time
um
Corrections have been identified since
the publication of the accounts to date
and they are included in paragraph of
4.3 explanations of those
um are contained within that section but
I would highlight one particular one
regarding a impact on the bottom line of
around 10 000 pounds following the the
correction identified uh what I would
say as well is that the audit is ongoing
so these figures are provisional at this
stage and it's not a complete list it's
just a highlight to members at an early
stage some of the current findings
for 21 22 accounts Malden was one of
only 63 of districts to publish their
unaudited accounts by the deadline the
audit of these accounts is expected to
commence in January um sorry in July
following completion of the 2021
accounts
for 23 24 and the following four years
of audits a national procurement
exercise was undertaken due to the
issues highlighted in the report a
significant increase in audit fees of
150 percent is advised to be expected
with the actual fees due to be announced
in the Autumn the council's current
auditor is leaving the market and the
council's new auditor will be kpmj uh
KPMG for that period and a bit of text
around who they are is contained within
the reports
um thank you Mr Leslie does any other
officers wish to speak at this time
before I open it up to debate for
members no okay members
um councilor Thompson and then councilor
stilts please
um thank you chairman um first of
several I suspect at 6.8 the audit fees
I think it's inconceivable that that
could be that kind of money for an
authority of this size apart from
anything else and it's an extraordinary
burden on the taxpayers to code with
that is there any way around this any
any anything please help somebody thank
you chairman thank you Mr Leslie would
you like to come back because we
discussed this didn't we in the
different size of councils and there's
not a lot of choice but thank you no the
challenges are those airlines in the
report in terms of the audit sector
unfortunately the amount of work
required in an audit is is still the
same sort of level compared to a big
Authority as well because they still
will do the checks they will go through
the usual processes and undertake those
things and they will change their um
level of materiality as well in in
accordance with the size of the council
so Amity reality will be lower than a
big Authority and therefore all the work
will be very similar certainly around
the valley for money requirement
um obviously the all member briefing
highlighted some of the costs we
expected and it showed actually the
level of the external audit fees in
terms of our actual gross expenditure as
well so it is a sizable increase but we
won't know for sure the actual figure
until the Autumn time around that so it
could potentially for it to be more
could be potential for it to be less
hopefully
thank you um cancer stilts please oh
thank you madam chair
um for clarity uh page 10 item 4.2
it says that Deloitte has worked at
various points on the audit and is
suspect expected to conclude in the
early part of next year
having scheduled resources to commence
in January so are they going to sign off
the accounts this January next January
or in January in the future and if they
don't sign it off will it have to go to
the new Auditors to be re-audited
yeah okay I think just for clarification
thank you exactly so it talks about 4.2
yeah it does talk about the deadline and
as at November 2022 there are still 160
audit points outstanding so it was
referring to at the time of writing it
was referring to the January 23 time
after November so apologies for the
confusion there but he's talking about
this generating indeed from the
conversations the authors have been in
um now in January time so the update I
think I gave in my introduction was that
they are in now looking to review
February with a view to sign off end of
end of March um April time now is the
current time frame and we have a better
picture as their work progresses
foreign
a couple of questions really for the 151
officer I mean
when we entered into a five-year
agreement with the psaa which I know is
a separate limited company to the
service that it provides or the service
providers that it employs
um clearly Council weren't aware of the
likelihood of the 24-25 audit being a
quarter of a million pounds
um
I mean I'm curious you know I've always
been curious is that no you're sorry
um I've always been curious to
understand the relationship between the
PSA a limited and the people that they
use to provide this service and actually
what they top slice to do it because I
think it's more than just a buying
Syndicate I mean there's several
Auditors so I suppose it begs the
question is what would happen if we went
to KPMG or another auditor to have this
work done
so that sort of concerns me and I mean I
I know that you will talk regularly to
other 151 officers in your cohort in
Essex and I just wonder what they
thought about this because you know I
suspect something like Essex County
Council or the police Authority they
could be starting off with like a base
level of about a million pounds which is
going to go up to two and a half million
pounds so clearly this isn't sustainable
I understand what what's said in this
report and there was a time when we used
to have our own internal uh Auditors
that used to work independently
um and I wondered if there was any way
that maybe that could be picked up upon
again to try and reduce this huge fee in
the future and and just finally a sort
of uh
um a sort of a housekeeping thing
um paragraph nine under implications I
mean I I know a lot of members often go
to implications because we you know
there was a time once when we used to
agree to have an executive summary at
the beginning of each report that went
to committees but that seems to
disappear now but a lot of them tend to
go to the implications and I think it's
good particularly around uh impact on
resources Financial that we actually
have a summary rather than just saying
read the report because I I fear
sometimes that members are often too
busy to do so and I think also that
applies to the impact on resources human
which you you talk to in the report but
I think you say none so there's a couple
of things there but I I think this is
something that really should be reported
individually back to council so they're
aware the situation because you know
this is going to have a massive off the
top of my head this is going to add I
suspect 10 to the bottom line isn't it
in 20 for 24.25 that'd be about right
1.5 million 150 000. so you know that
really does start to shift the drawdown
on our reserves so I I'm not expecting
to answer all those questions now but
perhaps I've written an answer maybe for
the benefit of the committee would be
useful
Mr Leslie yeah thank you uh the psaa um
they were set up uh part of the LGA so
there are almost a subsidiary I think
actually a substitute of the subsidiary
of the LGA as well um on that side so
that's where their link comes in
obviously set up to as a national
procurement agency I think given the
challenges and obviously Council
considered the approach for procurement
given the challenges around the sector
at the moment actually
um it felt that our bargaining power
will be stronger as a collective rather
than one individual given the actual
shortages of resources around that side
of it we had um we'll still have
internal orders we've got external and
internal Auditors provide very different
functions
um we do have outsourced internal
Auditors um still and this is this is
separate from the internal these are
external because we have BDO as
Errington Auditors as well who obviously
present um here so so they are separate
um yes we speak about this and obviously
concerned that this is one of many
pressures councils
um have at the moment
um and indeed one of my fears was that
um not only the staff and actually the
additional work that orders are required
will
create additional work for councils as
well because if they're doing more work
who's providing them with the
information and the evidence to support
that and what it will be coming from the
council so that was certainly one of my
concerns which I I raised at the group
um as well I'll take the point about
implications things always have to have
feedback and understand how MMS can
benefit from improvements in the report
so take them on board thank you for that
and yes it is a sizable percentage I
think in the old member briefing in
terms of our non-staff and expenditure I
think was about 2.6 percent of our
non-staff in Gross expenditure which is
probably about one point half of that
probably just over one percent of our
gross expenditure so actually it's a
sizable chunk of money absolutely
okay councilor Fluker
okay lovely okay thank you members
anybody else okay so I'm going to move
to the recommendation the recommendation
members is that members consider the
report do I have a second to please
councilor Fleming thank you uh members
agreed by ascent
thank you thank you members
moving on to agenda item seven review of
corporate performance quarter two pages
15 to pages 46.
um I'd like to welcome misuse to present
this report good evening Miss Hughes
there you go it's open to you
so this Ripple
report plan performance from July 22 to
October 22. uh section 3.1 shows the
high level outcome view for each theme
area and then section 3.2 also gives you
performance
um and the risk for individual kpi
levels
uh within Prosperity there are a number
of red areas and just to give a little
bit of assurance about
um Prosperity is we expect works such as
the covid economic response Grant
programs the cert program and the
forthcoming UK shared Prosperity fund
program should help address business
need and the sense of place business
network has been disbanded and a new
approach to supporting local businesses
has been developed this will include a
business e-newsletter along with social
media and open invite business
engagement events this will be rolled
out for quarter one of over 23 24 with
new performance measures and an update
provided then and we also expect that
our UK share Prosperity program will
yield significant results and engagement
with Partners so far has been
constructive
um the primary work stream for enabling
investment and jobs
or Prosperity is the creation of a
modern District
investment prospectus
and that has been delayed but we expect
the prospectus to launch in this quarter
so um although those
um areas of work aren't showing in the
performance report we just wanted to
highlight that to give a bit of
assurance
um overall members are asked to review
the report presented and confirm
assurance that corporate performance is
being managed effectively
um thank you Miss Hughes
um members the recommendations are found
on page 15 of the report the
recommendations are a little one that
members review the information are set
out in this report and appendix one with
priority Focus given to the Strategic
outcome level performance and little two
that members confirm they are assured
through this review that corporate
performance is being managed effectively
members what I'd like to do is to go
through the the reports on agenda 7 and
agenda 8 that we go through the appendix
Page by page so I'm going to call it out
and if members would like to speak on it
if you just bear with me and forgive me
if I don't see because I'll be reading
in in the correct order it won't be
personal so we're going to move on page
20.
um cancer stilts please
thank you madam chair
um after we had quite a long meeting
about colors and
um the way that this um was laid out I'm
quite disappointed that we're still
using lots of red and green and black on
white
when these are
things that can cause people with
disabilities quite a lot of problems and
I wonder if we have looked at
um people though the way that we do
these reports and the colors that we use
Miss Hughes I think we had a meeting
didn't we would you like to um put your
screen on and just give us an update
yeah we did in those colors um that are
showing in the report now were the ones
that were agreed
meeting and obviously we kept the red
and green for being able to track where
we were at risk or on track with
outcomes and but what we've done is
changed the gradients and the boldness
of some of the texts
um but the report is showing us per um
discussions in that or blind meeting
obviously further on in the report that
so we've only used the green and red
um for the high level where we're on
track or not and throughout the rest of
the report we're using the pastel colors
I can actually say I don't think it's a
shouty so thank you for that it hasn't
hurt my eyes and I've been looking at
these reports all day so I think you've
done quite a lot of work
um cancer stilts is right though we're
going to go through the red and green as
it comes up mysterious we've got some
maybe some suggestions later any
questions though members I'll move on to
page 21 councilor stilts
thank you madam chair
um page 21 and I'm looking at the bottom
bit which is total fly tipping removals
and we have a figure and it says
excluding investigation and enforcement
costs can you tell us what that figure
would be including
investigation and enforcement costs
um Mr Holmes is that you uh yes I think
that it could be calculated I haven't
got that figure so this is sort of
contractors costs but obviously we're
talking about staff time and we don't
record time necessarily Case by case
like that well I'll certainly make an
inquiry to see how easy it would be to
find out would you be able to report
back to members I can report back to the
committee the committee thank you
22. oh sorry councilor fluke are going
to 21.
um
[Music]
a
fixed payment hypnosis for 130 pounds
and I actually said well that's really
big story
I'll show how proactive would be
nothing
and I think that's what we needed to do
because you know this is
a problem particularly out about town
so
I think you know a bit more information
about so that we judge our performance
at the moment we seem to be judging the
performance of the fire service as
opposed to what we are doing
um to try and combat this so I'll I'll
park it there and leave those thoughts
with us at home thank you I think that's
a very good point because even on my
piece of paper I did write prosecutions
in big letters so I think that's
actually a very valid point to Mr Holmes
if if we could have some information
that would be fantastic
absolutely nothing that's that's an
important element isn't it how we
respond so yes I'm looking to how we can
report those steps thank you
22
minutes actually asked to speak and he's
in attendance from the beginning of the
meeting so if you'd like to make a note
thank you Berner thank you
thank you madam chair
um on page 22 when you're looking at the
prom Park and Riverside Park
satisfaction and the resident
satisfaction we seem to have had a quite
a big drop in the satisfaction of their
places and our businesses
um do we know why we've got a big drop
and I think I brought it up on the last
meeting as well that there was this big
drop
um
do do you know Miss Hughes or yes
[Music]
we've reported last meeting that the
resident business survey was live which
is completing the analysis at the moment
and then we'll be able to report the 20
the latest figures on that and the
comments that go with it so we'll have a
report to update that 20 so we we're all
hopeful it's going to go up to 80
percent aren't we yeah
um cancer lag and I'll do cancel if Luca
because he's a member and then you
please I'll always give away but I've
only got a quick one
um just with regards to page 22
um there are more District Council owns
and operates other public open spaces in
the district particularly uh Orchard
Meadows and Woodside in South Minister
and can I thank the um the director of
Service delivery for me to meet at those
Parks early on during this week
um you know we shouldn't lose sight of
the fact you know we focus on on
Riverside and Promenade and I think
you'd get some really good feedback if
you included those to be fair and then
we can start looking at the feedback
from those I appreciate that they're
quite different Open Spaces but they are
nevertheless managed by Morden and I
think it's only popper that we we
actually take those into consideration
in the future thank you chairman I think
that's noted don't you thank you Council
Lagan thank you chair that was just
councilor still says basically asked the
main question that I was going to ask
um because I'm interested because if the
satisfaction survey is dipped which then
you can only deal with the evidences in
front of you now again Council still
said why after the strategies and
efforts that we've been putting in so
I've been interested to see what the
commentary is because as I read the
report this is a lot of commentary but
this is certainly haven't started a
management plan yet so we're still
nowhere forward with what we need to do
to get that satisfaction survey up so
I'll be pleased to look at that yeah I
totally agree and I I have just one
quick question
um it says in the body of the report
about the UK shared Prosperity fund
investment plan and I've just put in my
own ways normal update do we have an
update when is that going to be
completed and I think it goes further in
to say something about a template so do
we have an update on that misuse
this is going to be updated UK shared
Prosperity fund the best investment plan
oh sorry Mr Dodson sorry sorry Cheryl
so in terms of the UK SPF funding that's
now being confirmed by government so so
that's in place it were you you look at
it in
terms of a specific yeah
what what is it going to mean for us it
means a million pounds worth of funding
over the next two and a half years
effectively
um a small amount of that
um in the current year
um the projects this year around mold
and market enablement fund enablement
funding for for business support
um a feasibility study
um
sorry I'm saying that I'm reading from
the from the um
rather than the the profile of where
they are that's under supporting local
businesses I can I can give a breakdown
of the the schedule I've got all the
projects here but I can give him by
which year and where where they're
profiled within that because I think
it's important we know as a committee
what we're getting the money and where's
it going we should be shouting that and
saying how how brilliant that is rather
than you know I was struggling all the
time I think that'd be lovely thank you
Mr Dodson
um councilor Edwards
thank you chairman I just wanted to
um add to council fluka's comments
regarding other Open Spaces
um Elm Farm Park in Cambridge is can I
ask if there's any flight tipping events
um taking place there recently
and I have been in contact with Mr
Holmes regarding Elms Farm Park and the
management of it
um but I just wonder if that can be
included as well and if there has been
any instances in in the last year or two
thank you I think it's quite important
because I actually read upon the old
data on that today as well so yeah
Mr Holmes Mr Holmes I don't I can't
confirm we've had or haven't had any
flight tipping on that particular site
but I certainly will look at that as in
the response to the committee on that
basis
um and yes we've discussed sort of Open
Spaces generally we will look at many of
these groups used to have friends groups
and they used to have consultation
through those which over the time on
southminster still has a very active
group and I was pleased to meet them
earlier this week
um so we will be discussing that again
and to say is there something we can
look at and how we can sort of put that
back and that will hopefully give us
engagement and obviously with members as
well
thank you
um page 23 members cancer stilts
thank you madam chair it's really for
clarity for me
um we talk on the graphs of percentage
household and percentage residential
recycling rates what is the difference
between residential and household
is that Mr Holmes
can we just clarify I think it says
household and residual waste
residual I think it says where does it
say that it says recycling on mine both
of them say recycling I don't know it
says
oh okay
all of us yeah it was
thank you Mr Holmes anybody else
councilor Edwards and then counselor
I've got your surname Fleming Jane thank
you uh chairman um
the residents of hobby is originally
received the leaflets with the door
regarding soft packaging trials
in haybridge but the trial is not in
haybridge
is it Mr Holmes I thought it was Modern
District
I have to double check there are um
locations throughout the district which
are part of the travel system maybe not
the holiday Bridge it could even be down
to street level in Highbridge and it
will specify on the form but if you're
saying it's not in Hobbies at all right
but all the residents hopers have
received it in the post okay I think
someone's actually from the prize
council's already created as well okay
they're all asking now when is it
starting of course it's not okay thank
you unless it's starting in October 2020
23 this year we'll look into that
Council redwoods thank you for raising
it thank you anybody else no page 24
members oh sorry counselor cancer
Fleming I do apologize
thank you chair
um I think we're on page 23. yeah uh yep
um it was the air quality management
area I just wanted to uh ask when when
we'll know whether our bid for funding
has been successful not sure who that
would be yeah
my understanding is it will be late
February or early March so we never got
haven't got a specific date for it but
um I understand is it will be later in
February um it's the beginning of March
thank you Mr Holmes
um page 24
there's a red on here cancer stilts
okay
please yeah thanks I mean
this air quality management plan
particularly our Market Hill has been
going on for a long time now a very very
long time and I'm reading now I'm
absolutely staggered at the response to
Essex County Council
um you know we're talking about
carcinogenic
um elements here coming from vehicles I
mean I there was you've got three-way
traffic signals at the top of Market
Hill and I mean it was absolutely
extraordinary the other day it took me
35 minutes to get from the roundabout to
the first traffic signal and you could
just smell it in the air you know it
really is bad but of course when we did
this we also found another place where
pollution is really bad
um and that's to the
um east of latchingdon where the the
roundabout is and it was right on the
edge of the acceptable EU standard
um what that means now I don't know
um but you know we shouldn't lose sight
of that because with all the new
developments that have come forward in
South Minster in Burnham and the fact
that more and more cars are going
morning we shouldn't lose sight of the
fact that we probably need to monitor
again at that location and of course
that type of information gives good
Prejudice to to plan in applications
when they come forward so perhaps that's
something that Mr Holmes could take up
come back to us on in the future thank
you
um yeah um the latchingdon air quality I
actually queried that
um I think maybe a year ago I can't
remember which planning officer told me
that wasn't an issue anymore it had
actually right in itself it wasn't
earned because I said well where's the
monitors so I'd be really interesting to
see if that is still the case because I
was told there wasn't an issue because
when the ldp first time around it was
identified that that what council Fluker
said was a bottleneck and that was one
of the reasons why the development
wasn't going out there but I know I did
query it and that was the answer I got
um and just does can you answer the
question what cancer fluke said why is
Essex County Council I got to declare an
interest I'm a member of six County
Council but obviously it's not my War
but why is it taken them so long is
there any reasons did the meeting stop
Mr Holmes do you know I believe they
paused around the um the beard but Mr
Gill is on the uh call remotely so I
think he'd be able to answer that
question for you so uh yes please
Damian Gayla Mr Gala Damien
could you could you help us welcome
can you tell me why or tell the
committee why it's taken so long to have
any result or progress from Essex County
Council regarding the
um the current High fumes shall we say
on Market Hill
um cancer fluka quite rightly said it's
been going on a long time now and it
doesn't seem to progressed
felt with a funding bid and this was
going back if it will last and so really
all the work on the air quality action
plan stalled the other reason was that
the destination survey of the GCC were
commissioned to do they kept on saying
during covid it's not typical traffic
flow so we need to pause and we need to
make sure the traffic bonus turns to
normal and when it did Then They carried
out destination server but that was some
time after
um the destination survey we've got now
the work that they've done to look at
that area
um
and what members originally discussed
many you know a couple of years ago
there are some differences there
um but having said that literally day
before yesterday Essex County Council
highways partners and Walden officers
had a meeting to literally talk about
the very basics of Market Hill and
adjusting traffic flow so that was very
positive and hopefully with the funding
come in the the bid being decided the
appropriate March if that comes through
we can then look at our whole air
quality action plan we can regulate the
existing plan as it is and we can bring
that back to members and hopefully start
to push forward on this so my apologies
has taken so long that's some of the
reasons why but we are open to get it
back on track
Council Fleming would you like to yes I
thought you might cancel Fleming thank
you chair thank you Damon um can I just
double check
um Have you shared the results of the
destination survey with the modern Focus
the High Street Focus Group
um I'm not sure would
with the this committee like to see the
results of that certainly because
councilor fluke has raised a very valid
point and so have you so yes if we could
have it reported back yeah if you could
share that Damien thank you
okay members anybody else
no 25
cancer stilts please
um yeah it's just a question
um that as the delivery the housing
needs for the district is at risk and we
know that at the moment we have this
financial crisis implication on mortgage
rates and build out right
um we are quite below Target are we
expecting to fall further below Target
or are we hoping that we might pick up
some of this target that we're aiming
for because the targets have been
increased it's a good question who who's
going to be able to answer because I
don't think there's anybody on from oh
yes there's um Anne and and would you be
able to answer that question please
not Anne not Yuan the other one not
counselor you you hello Anne yes
I think we'll see a slow down maybe
filtering through next year from things
that the developers are telling us they
are slowing the
completion rates down but they're
slowing their start rates down so the
completions that come through at the
other end will start to slow down at the
moment it's it's still filtering through
house this is still called filtering
through but I think as we move into the
new Financial year we might see a slow
down in completions
um thank you could I ask a little
question on there do other developers
going to hold back on the affordable and
and build the market value ones
I don't think
I don't think they can because I don't
think it's part of their planning a lot
of their planning permissions
I've got affordable triggers in them so
I'm not sure that they can okay
if there's an economic
situation developers will build their
affordable before their Market because
there's a more a bigger guarantee
good well that's fine
well that that could help us then
couldn't it really so um
in the 2008 crash you know would have
been crushed to a building completely
stopped it was the affordable housing
that carried on being built not the
market housing okay
um Council fluka and then Council Lagan
yeah thanks chairman I mean I think I
can't remember the figures off to my
head now but
you know I think I mentioned it the last
last meeting of maybe it was Council
that how many people were actually on
our housing list you know how many
homeless people there are and very sadly
how many people at the moment and it's
quite a large number for modern District
Council are actually in temporary
accommodation bed and breakfasts and as
I said they're as far away as peace
power I mean I see this as a very
important point and I I think you know
the officers should do everything they
possibly can to address this this
affordable housing and I think the
members should get behind them thank you
totally agree Council Lagan yeah I'm not
not being really weird but I forgot my
glasses so I can't see a thing without
the light I feel for you yeah I feel for
me because of the notes I've made I
can't read
um so apologies chair and apologies
members and apologies officers and
apologies anybody who's watching them
um it's a comment about the very last
um line in the report where it says the
five-year housing land Supply and
housing delivery test remain as reported
in q1 is that correct because we did we
did a recalculation of the five-year
housing land Supply where we had an
increase
and as we're going through the working
group that may change
so the two the the question is is that
the same because in quarter one I
thought we had a lower figure
and because we've increased the figure
not to Five Years yet
and
does the impact of our review
through the working group because that
would move that part of the at-risk down
from red to Green
um
and
we only put in the uh
core Pro performance we only put the
information that we publicly published
so we've got that won't change until we
publish Again The Five-Year Supply which
is normally in April so so it's quarter
one so it was originally published in
quarter one which is April so we expect
a review of The Five-Year land Supply in
April this year but are you still
um keeping it because you when we've
questioned you before with this
committer you've actually said you're
keeping a tight Reign on you know day to
day or roughly week to week uh how are
we doing
yeah how are we doing are you allowed to
tell us
[Music]
was it okay that's fair enough I totally
understand that but but some you might
be able to help me or somebody can help
me maybe Mr Holmes or Mr Dodson I think
there's been a planning appeal this week
was it was it declared at the planning
appeal would that would it have to be
declared at the planning material
directors
do you know
Tottenham the bull
was that this week it can be declared it
depends if it's challenged within it I'm
not I'm not aware that it was it was
declared or used as a figure within that
so we'd have to check would you mind
checking because I do think if it can be
um said Thank you And and Mr Dodson
because I think it's important to
members that they do know and are kept
up to date on this
um thank you Ann um Council fluka yeah
chairman this is you know
I understand how this works and I've
I've spoken to miss shortland about this
and and I understand that she's going to
report back more fully at the five-year
housing land Supply working group on the
2nd of February I think it is okay but
you know the these this is very very
very sensitive information and I think
it's right and proper that we don't set
um anything running before we are 100
sure on the facts I totally agree but we
we've also got to be consistent and
we've got to remember February last year
a figure was was
um published and it was an inaccurate
figure so it's important that we do keep
a check on it counselor fluco but thank
you look forward to seeing you on the
second of Hope yep you most probably
won't look forward to seeing me but
anybody else members page 25. now moving
on 26 please there's another red
anybody
um councilor again yeah I only basically
repeat what I said earlier on with
regard to the top one
about the land Supply but I think we've
discussed that thank you
um
forgive me calling you Anne because I
always get your surname um Miss
shortland
um I I looked at this one and I was a
little bit
mixed up because it says on here about
this could be the covered impact that
has caught up with the district I'm sure
I've attended many meetings and was told
that the Kobe didn't have any
um effect on the five year land Supply
or whatever so can I have Clarity did we
have has have we have or now we're
finding out that we are having problems
due to covid that's affected our
five-year land Supply are you are you
able to answer that or am I asking you a
tricky question
was captive
you know when we were all in lockdown I
I couldn't see a lot of impact on the
housing market in the district but then
normally the housing market goes and
kind of waves so afterwards you might
see an impact and actually if there
isn't any impact it's being clouded by
the cost of living crisis yeah it just
concerns me that in the report Ms jotlin
is that it just say this could be that
the covert impact has caught up like
just just bothers me that you know
without the correct or backup data I
feel a little bit uncomfortable than
it's in if members are all right with it
then I'm absolutely fine I just wanted
to raise it as a a query members are you
all right for that to stay in the report
okay I'm in the minority
anybody else
27.
capsular stilts and cancer fluka uh
thank you madam chair I'm just
um I know that we haven't yet employed
the coast and Countryside roll
um but I am surprised that we actually
haven't looked at planting any trees
when Malden Town Council were planting
trees and surely they're a partner that
we could have helped or looked into Mr
Holmes
absolutely correct um there are if
things have been happening but we
haven't got anybody to actually
coordinate that and record that at the
moment so it doesn't mean it hasn't
retrieved planted but it's not being
done in a coordinated way um the good
news is that we are um interviewing this
week for that post um we hope that we'll
have an officer in post
um shortly after and that is obviously
part of their work plan so um I've left
this you know the honors position is we
haven't had the resources now for two or
three months we just haven't had anybody
coordinate that work but that will be on
the work plan
um for catching up as soon as we got
them in post okay councilor fluka thanks
chairman um
you know the Ashwood and denji Bradwell
and tellingham litter Pickers hung up
their Pickers and came out with their
shovels and we planted roughly 2 000
trees
so across that sector
so you know I think a simple a simple
way maybe when this new person is is
appointed I think most of those trees
came from the Woodland trust or through
some other it's just a you know it's to
just to you know tap into that core
information or even just to send an all
Parish Council and said how many trees
you planted because if we can get
something in those two boxes if there's
some green funding comes along then we
can actually clearly demonstrate that
we're doing this and the good news is
it's not costing more than District
Council anything to tick this box so you
know when the new tree officer comes
along
um you know by all means ask him to
email me and I'll give him a few
pointers and he can come out next time I
think that's a fair Comics I I know um I
think um oh
Mr whittendale came to one of Burnham
where we planted trees in the church and
I know it's on Council land but we
communities are planting trees and I
think it'd be really good to actually
promote that we are doing what we can
yeah totally agree with that as I say
it's the coordination of it it's the
recording of it so it looks worse than
it probably is so we just haven't got
the data but as has suggested that it's
a fairly quick way to do that so that'll
be cool that's nice to know we are
actually doing it because it looks as
though we're not doing it so thank you
um page 28 members
no 29
cancel login please
make sure I've got the right paging
it's got number six Prosperity on the
top ah there you go I can't even see
that
um
it's a really good report because it
allows you to drill down so thank you
Miss Hughes but we're not from the
perspective of performance measurement
we're talking about a Target I think
what do we call it a business list
satisfaction
um
at the bottom yeah
the modern District Council Services has
a percentage and we've set a target for
30 percent okay
and in the commentary which is read
one two three lines down it uses a
really dangerous word it says our
assumption is that
the satisfaction
etc etc which I wish I could read I
really don't understand the the word of
it's using an assumption in there and I
think if you accept 30 as a committee I
think that's terrible
I think you when you're aiming for
something of that high satisfaction you
don't go for 100 you should have a 75 80
aspiration or a Target at least but if
you're going to accept 30 percent
well which is plummeting there's
something wrong somewhere so that would
send a red flag to me I think we have
questioned haven't we Cheryl misuse the
the percentages that members have raised
concerns before that they're quite low
and you normally can come up with the
reasons why they are can you help Mr
Council again
is only 30 years because that's higher
than what the previous year was so we're
trying to beat the previous year's
satisfaction and obviously we're in the
middle of crunching the numbers on the
resident and business survey so we'll
know what that number is soon but we did
get much better engagement from the
businesses in the resident and business
survey and largely because the PO
officers actually did sort of a door
knocking exercise and did on on
in-person engagement to get the
responses and so we're hoping to get
better feedback this time as well okay
thank you of course you can't catch
Logan and thank you Mrs
what's to appreciate it I still go back
to my initial point that China beat last
year's percentage is just if my word is
unacceptable on offering a service you
talk about modern District councils
satisfaction service to businesses and
if you're prepared to set 30 I looked at
that and and that was a big thing that
jumped out at me I thought all the hard
work that you're doing and all the great
things that you've just said that that
Target is not good enough it's not good
enough for us as a council it's not good
enough for me as an individual if I I've
said that you set the bar really low the
bar might be low but we want the reality
of setting it to 75 to 80 and then we're
saying we're only getting 30 or 35 and
then it could be a surprise if you come
in at 45 to 50 so our percentiles are
getting closer and closer but I think
that and also using an assumption we
think it is you've got to have the data
we've got to interrogate the data so you
get the fact of the information of why
aren't people satisfied and then once
you've got that you can set your
strategy G and when you've got that you
can Implement your policies to go and
actually improve that so whilst I
appreciate the Fantastic work that's
being done if I was on this committee I
believe it
um you're going to provide the data you
said anyway aren't you so we'll have to
wait for that to be provided yeah thank
you um cancer Fleming then councilor
fluka please
thank you chair actually I wanted to go
back to page 28 the yep infrastructure
funding statement
um it says is next year for publication
April May 2023 I think this one's for Mr
Leslie I think every Council has to
publish one or by by December I thought
it was 31st of December so and could we
as members of this committee or all
members have a copy of that if we could
circulate it thank you Mr Dodson please
yes the deadline is December we actually
brought it forward to March so that
we're we're aligning it with with the um
the financial year rather than doing it
through the calendar year but but it
means we're we're effectively reporting
earlier in the year than the deadline
which would would be
um December
um I believe that report does come to to
this committee when it's when it's
published so so when we go through that
it will come through here thank you um
cancer fluka yeah thank you chairman I I
think when you look at the information
on page 29 from my perspective you can't
run a business if you've got a
satisfaction rate a 30 end of but this
is completely different to a business
but what would be useful whenever we've
got information like this is to see how
how many responses it's based on because
if we've got 10 000 responses and it's
only 30 30
then you know we really do need to do
something but if we've got you know
hundreds it paints a completely
different picture because when you get a
very very small response to a survey it
tends to be active so I think maybe if
if it's possible to put another little
box on that page in the future so we can
see what responses are I think we can
understand it more contextually then
thank you thank you Mrs nodding and
before we move on to page 30
um
um uh councilor Edwards Mr Holmes has
got a an answer to your question
regarding recycling Mr Holmes
thank you chairman yes um there is an
error made in Holloway Road and the
leaflets were distributed but the good
news is because of that era and they now
are part of the trial hey I also under I
also understand the street in Mainland
had the similar issue and they are also
part of the program that's nice
okay thank you okay
um Council Fleming would like to speak
he's on page 29 councilor Fleming
I'm sorry uh regrettably a number of
factors have impacted our sense of place
approach I just wondered if we could
sort of drill down on that of it are we
allowed to say what they are what are
they
who who will take that because it's
usually Mr Ellum isn't it Mr Dodson can
you take that one
yes yes chair I can pick it up thank you
um there were a number of factors one
was the resignation of the existing
chairman and the representation on the
board of of the businesses that that
were on there
um
was waning
um so whilst it we're definitely will
and are retained in the sense of place
um branding and marketing which is
really great the the board themselves
um agreed that they wouldn't go ahead in
the the current form that doesn't mean
we won't be engaging with businesses and
we won't be engaging with some of those
businesses that were on the the sense of
place board we'll just do it in a
slightly different way and we're
finalizing how we're doing that and
that's more likely to be
um probably a couple of sort of business
forums a year and then then through the
the website and the create the networks
that way rather than through the
existing I think it says on the next
page doesn't it a little bit more
information and I think Mr relum sent an
invitation out about some changes has he
Mr Dodson I'm sure I've read an email
inviting us to something to do with
businesses I think so okay
all right page 30 members
uh Council stilts please thank you madam
chair it seems to go on from page 29
um and we're now looking at supporting
existing local businesses and that's at
risk and when you look at the charts
that are below it
um we seem to have a growth in
subscribers to sense of place business
communication channels What channels are
they and also we talk about are we
getting redoing the sense of place and
if so how will that affect now
Mr Dodson
uh the engagements through the the
center Place newsletter
um as I say we're reviewing
um how we do that we will still be
looking to make contact with all of
those businesses and maintain that
database of of businesses and as I say
The Branding will remain so we won't
lose any of that work we'll continue the
engagement with those businesses just in
a slightly different way
okay page 31 members
um councilor stilts please
um
sorry that's fine
my question on page 31 is really
about tourism and I've got done do we
have any figures for the 2022 on the
tourism growth
um
so when we're looking at the tourism to
The District in pound and growth
percentage we've got 2021 but we got
nothing for 2022 at all
can you answer that question
there's just quite a lag on that data um
coming through so we will get it but um
it hasn't been published yet or it
hasn't been published as of quarter two
okay
um would you would you to explain
because I sent you an email didn't a
question about the the tourists and
you've got modern District tourist
tourism group
um because you sent somebody sent me the
link I'll try to log on to it and I
can't get into it I think it's a
volunteer group is it because I wanted
to know what we did as a district and at
the moment we're not doing a great deal
are we so you you pointed me to a
Facebook group
yeah yeah do you want to explain it to
members because then they know what you
are what the council is doing
yeah so um this is passed on through um
tourism sector consultative group
um for the council's tourism framework
so they um
basically help inform the strategy so
group is supported by the modern
District tourism group which I think is
the link that you're talking about at
the upset link
and it's
and there's
um but in terms of activity two events
have been held in 2022 and with industry
representatives and council members and
I believe councilor still to sit on the
t22 so you might be able to share some
more information with the group
um the idea is that
um
it would be sort of an open Forum where
um people can come together to give
steer and feed into them
tourism
strategy
okay
um councilor fluka
I'm always curious when we look at these
figures where they actually come from I
I can remember in the past we used to
subscribe to a company that used to
provide us with figures but I've not
seen those for a long time so it from
from what Miss Hughes says the 22
figures are available for tourism
um so if we're still using that company
to provide a report can it be circulated
to the members of this committee
because um Mr Dodson please
yes we should get get figures through
through visit Essex
um I need to check where we are with
those
um and we'll we'll circulate those if
they're available now or we'll report on
them within the the next quarter I just
wanted to add to what what Mrs Hughes
said
um slightly there as well as the support
that that she outlined we do have host
the visit Malden website
um and work closely with with um
businesses tourism-based businesses and
food and drink businesses and all of
those linked with the visitor economy
um through that website and and promote
there and um you know similar figures I
can quote you know we have four million
visitors a year
um through through tourism
um into the district which is
um a much bigger percentage of the
overall visitors to to um Essex than the
the size of our population so so we are
sort of punching above our weight as we
should do given the attractions of of
molden and we're also
Mr Allen is putting together the tourism
framework which will set out some of the
wider support that's going through which
we will bring forward through strategy
and resources Committee in due course
I think it might be worth committee
Services looking back because in the
past we did used to pay for a report on
tourism it wasn't an Essex County
Council it was some other group that we
used to subscribe to and it was very
good but I I mean I hear what you say
about four million people but that's 80
000 a week
seems to me quite a lot because
sometimes you go down to you know I was
down at the prom at the weekend and it
wasn't that busy down there but 80 000
people coming in and it's quite
interesting what I heard about the night
time and daytime economy in uh Burnham
last night so that's a huge amount of
people
um
yeah I mean you've got to figure it'd be
nice to see you know if we can yeah if
we can get the information on that and
perhaps find out who this company was
that used to provide this information
I'm sure they will cancel Luca councilor
Hull
uh we
um with writing school we do a buy gift
and that brings a lot of people in from
out the area
so
do you want to explain what that is to
everybody
um it's by a gift and people
um buy gifts from outside the area and
they come riding but we must get 25
Riders which come with their families
and it they always want to stay and do
things like that it's actually great do
many other businesses do that Mr Dodson
do you know buy a gift
sounds good
it does I I don't know that off the top
of my head or whether it's something
that that is promoted through the visit
molden website but it is an opportunity
there to do that it's like the Christmas
tree Wish isn't it okay members let's
move on oh I'll cancel again please
sorry just a quick one there's um you
must have gone down the prom a different
date of me counselor and I've actually
been moaning at Mr Holmes about the
amount of retained water that's turned
to ice now and my dog slipped over so
the vet spills on its way
um you Sandy it was heaving and it was
Heaven yeah come on members not a
talking shop
um the perceived benefit that the
businesses are getting Mr Johnson says
we're getting four million visitors
really it's quite it shocked me a bit
because it's lower than I thought for
the last reports I've read but the
percentage of benefit to those
businesses is quite low when you look at
that so it'd be interesting to see what
strategies come forward to actually help
the businesses that that can benefit
from from what we're going now because
it dips again it's a 30 we seem to
accept that level or report that level
so that would be something that I'd you
know we could focus upon to assist the
businesses in the district okay members
page 32 Council stilts
are you okay 32 33
I know
all right thank you madam chair
um looking at the business benefits
through tourism activities and
everything do we have any data on the
effect of the dropping commercial events
that we've had on the tourism in the
Parks and other places
um Mr butcher is not on the call so Mr
Holmes do you I do you have that
information or do you have to bring it
back
which I don't think we'd have to look at
that could you could you perhaps be look
perhaps explain a little bit more what
you're looking for and then I can I can
obviously get the officers to a
researcher for you yeah we we've uh run
less events in the prom this year
um as you know we lost two big events in
the prom being the car show and the
smoke and fire
um and I want to I just wondered how
that then impacts upon the tourism of
the town and the district
and a few years ago we ran quite a big
weekend event down in Burnham on the
Grape and Grain
and again that's something that's not
gone and we've not replaced it with
anything so I wondered how that has
affected our tourism
um absolutely we can have a look at sort
of comparators it's a little bit
difficult over the last three or four
years obviously with covid because it's
yeah pre-covered and then during the
period it naturally went quieter but I
can ask the question I think um going
forwards I think it's positive because a
number of events and some of the events
you mentioned potentially coming back as
well so you know 22 might have been a
quiet year but I'll see what information
I can find for you
button because it's also um
yeah the high streets and everything
when you've got these events coming I
know some some residents do complain
because of the the noise and the
inconvenience but
um I think generally when you do an
event it's good right let's move on
members because we're going to be all um
waning page 34. nope 35 I think we're
all on track 36.
35 councilor Hull
fat
they're getting fit
turn your microphone on sorry we started
a club
um with the fitness and trying to get
people that were fat to get fit it it
didn't evolve because actually the fit
the fat people kept wanting to know well
you are being recorded I'm just saying
they they all they just they didn't seem
to get involved because
that I kept wanting to stop for dinner
stop for lunch so so what was your point
so what happened no we had a lot of it
was over after the covid and it really
worked quite well yeah and we had got a
lot of younger people involved
um but my uh my what I'm trying to say
is was we there was somebody said oh you
can get a grant to help you with these
people and um because they were mostly
young and
um anyway we applied for the grant and
they said yes we should be able to do it
and it came to it and they said no we
couldn't they were mostly young it
worked out the teenagers that it ended
up going for walks or volleyball or
Cricket it worked you know we did it for
quite a long time
um but then
um the the
um in them the grant that we could have
got
um it didn't we couldn't get it for some
reason
um and then the youth club had 80 000
some pounds in their account last time
and I just wanted to take these people
you know to get fitter and stuff do they
are they able to get grants for doing
that can can anybody help because it's a
really valid point we will have been a
little bit giggly in places but I mean
we do know it is an absolute an issue
and the live well and everything we're
supposed to be starting younger aren't
we to encourage it Mr Mr Holmes can you
help or Mr Mr Dodson sorry thank you Mr
Dodson thank you chair
um we can certainly look at that there
were some grants made available through
the uh Medics Alliance
um for health and well-being
um and it's certainly a high priority
and and clearly within our
um health and well-being priorities
obesity is a clear one that we're
looking to address we don't give grants
directly but it's something that I can
get uh Mr Folger to look into a
community lead to check what grants are
available and circulate that information
I think it'd be able to help help you
councilor Hall as well yes you can come
back yeah oh no it was just the fact
that we didn't you know we didn't want a
lot of money but there's lots of clubs
that could use this money especially
like you know the Girl Guides or the
scouts or you know to keep people active
and or you know there's lots of times
but it just makes you feel a bit valued
doing something like that yeah speak to
Josh cancel stilts
um yeah I was just gonna ask Mr Dobson
isn't it active Essex for Essex County
Council that does that sort of thing
there's there's many that do active
Essex yes they they do promotions
through that we we have close links with
them through our
Sports development and health and
wellbeing offices as well a neighbor
okay
because members
they were green and 36 a cat's a Lagan
it's a couple of comments that you can
put me right if in this because it's
mental health and well-being which I
think is actually critical after what
we've been through for the covid
challenges we had and also the cost of
living increases the initiatives I mean
on the first um
a small type of the promotion of mental
health and loneliness that that seems to
be good for the for 2021 but we haven't
really kicked off a much obviously for
2023 but the thing that worries me more
is that in the middle part of it is the
number of integrated
um integrated projects delivered we've
got a target of one and we didn't do
that
is there is that just we haven't
captured that or
turn um do you know that Mr Dodson or Mr
Holmes
why we didn't even achieve the one
or misuse do you know the data behind it
yeah I think
it says intergenerational projects young
people and older people um
so I think
and shielding was largely
um
what impacted that one in particular
okay yes Mr Dodson please thank you
um it is one of our our key key
priorities and it is um
uh being developed further I mean the
promotion of Mental Health social
isolation and loneliness initiatives
um we are ahead of last year in terms of
that in terms of the the heading towards
the target of of 96.
um we've also through the one modern
District initiative it's one of the key
um priorities there and we're working
closely uh with our partners across the
the district
um it's one of the key key work streams
that's come out of that that work that
we'll be pursuing so it is a high
priority and we will be ensuring that
that it's given the attention it needs
thanks
uh thank you um Council Fleming did you
wish to speak on that no okay members
page 37
38
cancer stilts
thank you madam chair and I have brought
this one up before it's the percentage
of MDC customer facing staff who have
received make every count training and
I've asked before because last year as
you could see it just dropped off
um and this year it's still very low and
I would have thought our priority for uh
customer facing staff is to make sure
that every second does count
who wants to take that because I'm not
going to get involved because it's my
hobby horse isn't it
can we have yes we have Sue green on the
meeting this evening oh I didn't see a
picture there and I'm sure she bailed
her sisters thank you
it's green thank you Mrs Green
There She is welcome
um this this is because we have had a
fair bit of a staff turnover on our
customers team so it is absolutely key
priority for us and we will be working
um with Essex County
um in order to ensure that this is
delivered to all of our our new staff so
it is an ongoing item
um certainly staff is in our team have
an awareness of it it's just the
formality of going through that course
cancer stilts cancer stilts would like
to come back in the screen please yeah I
mean 80 what is it 83 Target last year
and and we're well below that 67 this
year
um
in I would have thought that with the
our staff when they start should do this
training before that she should be put
in place in their role
um you know we're expecting our staff to
talk to our customers
um
uh and we we're not giving them the
appropriate training
the screen
members this training is in regards to
identify those customers that have
seen on me so for example smoking
cessation or additional support that
they may need to be able to ensure that
they are appropriately passed on to the
relevant organization it isn't a general
contactless training it is very
specifically around and identified
additional support for our customers and
that's together for Everyone by partis
County Council
so in a few the next quarter or when we
get it two quarters time it's going to
be up to 80 or 90 I'm sure isn't it
because they'll all be trained yep okay
members page 39. thank you thank you 39.
40.
I feel like a bingo caller members yes
41 commercial outcomes
no no questions on Commercial outcomes
42
cancer stilts then Council Lagan
um thank you uh Madam chair it's
basically the houseboats again I think
we bring this up nearly every time
um where are we with the
hell I've just had the right eyebrows
from Mr Holmes uh Mr Holmes yes please
with nervousness members we anticipate
uh the Little League to be removed this
weekend coming up
um so everything's in place and we
understand that the the barge is being
positioned over this weekend and should
be hopefully floated into the uh the
barge itself which is a bit of a dry
dock and then it will be removed so
officers are monitoring over the weekend
we're in contact with the contractors
um Harbor authority to kind of keep up
to date on that and I shall going there
tomorrow morning also to get an update
have you got a pass
I should be I should be viewing from the
Sea World chairman
um and obviously following that that
will actually allow us to progress our
plans in terms of the actual houseboats
and The Moorings themselves so this is
obviously is a key a key moment so um
fingers crossed there's some good news
excellent
um councilor Thompson and then Council
Lagan
no and that's tempting fate Council
again I'm just going to give away to
councilor Hall if that's all right
councilor Hall I'm I'm just inquiring
about the Pontoon there as well I keep
being asked about it
um has anything more happened and
because I also brings in tourism and I
think a lot of the pubs say they're
they're not doing so well because
there's no pontoon there yeah do you
want to turn your lights out Mr Holmes
is going to give an update because
you're not the only one badgering week
on every day Mr Holmes uh thank you so
yes um obviously we've now been advised
of success for our funding around the
the actual um provision of that pontoon
um so I've got an officer group meeting
um next week to start looking at the
detail of that and I've committed to
update members on on the progress with
that
um it very much follows the work that's
been done with the the houseboat um
pontoon as well so we're hoping we can
pick up all of the learning and process
from that and actually apply it fairly
quickly so the sort of planning meetings
are starting to happen and I'll be able
to issue an update in terms of the
timing it will take some time we need to
make various applications planning
applications we also need to apply to
the MMO and we also have to um and
that's the maritime organization that
looks after our Coastline and we also
obviously have to address some of the
issues around the sea wall but um that
network is um is committing I could ask
a question before I'll go to council
Logan is it going to be like like for
light or have you got a different design
or have you not got that to that stage
yet Mr Holmes
I believe it's of a similar design but I
think uh stability being improved I
think it's slightly wider but I haven't
got the technical detail here thank you
Council Lagan please
it's only a comment there's some good
stuff on here but are the the first two
um the land acquisition and the princess
Road
um they're all green with regards to
what they're doing but after the recent
council meeting should they that was a
private confidential right so there's
things there that um to discuss in
private coverage yeah thank you uh
councilor bloke oh did you want to come
in
chairman only to say that
members to remember this this is the
report to the end of quarter two so so
it wouldn't have reflected the anything
that that was was in Council in the last
couple of weeks in any case uh
yeah thanks you and I you know look
um I was going to raise the same point
but
you know I think this is so important
that we understand this from from all
aspects of this Council so maybe
chairman
um moving forward this matter should be
dealt with
and the
um private confidential because there's
there's clearly uh issues there that I
think that you know we should we should
touch out can that be oh we've lost them
um mysterious can that be noted Berna
are you still with us yeah oh okay okay
um so uh the request is that the
commercial projects
yes
yes so we can have it as an agenda item
please when it's due to cancer fluid yes
sorry Kevin it's one really for you to
thrash out the agenda meeting but I
think that one there I think that first
one definitely is moving forward and and
I mean that way we can have a full
discussion yeah and Council fluke I
raised it because I'll most probably
forget when it comes to the next one so
if I turn this hugee will remind me
um yeah I'm sorry sorry Mr Dodson yeah I
can hardly see you so yeah thank you
chairman it was just to to um remind
members with um reference to that
specific project
um
um there there is a
um sorry members yeah there's a members
seminar that's being held on that to
enable a wider discussion on that
obviously that will happen outside of
the the formal meeting and members may
wish to have a more formal uh review of
that within here but just just to flag
that that discussion's happening as well
yeah
um page 43
uh cancer stilts please
um you know it's just to ask Mr Dobson
after the email that we got today where
are we at with this
um
project
um is this project still going to go
ahead on page 43
Mr Dodson yes yeah yes just just just to
clarify for for the record that that's
with reference to the leveling up fund
bid which we unfortunately received the
information today that we weren't
successful with that
um obviously we only received that that
information uh today
um we've not yet had the feedback on the
the bid only that we were unsuccessful
so we await the feedback on the the bid
um there is around three of leveling up
and obviously depending on the the
feedback that we get we'll look at
whether we resubmit for that but also
we'll do a review meeting once we get
the feedback to look at what other
routes are available for funding I think
we have to look at it you know as a
positive in some ways that
we've now got that bid together we've
done all of that work so we need to look
at alternative funding and also we've
got that on the Shelf now for if if
additional funding comes along but we've
not got a a funding plan for it at this
minute we need to do that review now I
was listening to some of the successful
bids that obviously has been locally in
Essex and the one that I thought was
super and I don't know if there's
something you could do because I'm a
little bit reticent about putting more
resources that take them from the the
jobs that the officers are doing to be
able to put a bid together and it was
all about Psychopaths and it was all
about you know
um yeah connectivity so really I mean I
know that Paul Burnham the Dengue in
southminster don't get included in very
much but I'm sure we would love to
actually have something that wasn't
modern Centric so we could actually have
that sort of funding bid to go forward
um because I'm I'm the same as you Mr
Dodson I'm actually following this quite
um succinctly at the moment because I'm
interested to know why the others are
successful and and why we haven't been
and to see what the government is
actually wanting councils to do to
enable them to win these bids so uh of
cancer fluka yeah thank you chairman I
mean I'm I'm on this one I'm pleased to
say that South Minster did actually get
um a substantial sum of leveling up
money
um and and uh and if you if you happy to
meet me in Seasons wood I'll show you
the
the the wooden animals that this money
was was spent on but I think one thing
about this project is and I think it it
says a lot about what we're doing with
the new community center and sports
Pavilion in in
um South Winston what I would urge
officers to do at this stage is to
submit the planning applications because
then you really will be oven ready if
something comes along and you you you
have to you know you have to act quickly
um because there's so much uncertainty
about it but I think with this
particular one I'm sure all of the
members will support it yeah so yeah
good point yeah but I think it's a good
idea to bring It Forward yeah Council
Fleming are you okay I was going to say
I agree with councilor fluka nice to
have it oven ready okay page 44.
no we're okay 45.
right members I'm going to read the
recommendation out again that members
review the information I set out on this
report and appendix one with priority
Focus given to the Strategic outcome
level performance little two that
members confirm that they are assured
through this review that corporate
performance is being managed effectively
I so proposed do I have a seconder
um Council of Fleming members do agree
by ascent great greats moving on agenda
item eight the review of the corporate
risk register quarter two pages 47 to
64.
um welcome issues again would you like
to present the report and I think we've
got
um Miss Damian Gaylor on hand if you've
got any questions members thank you
so this report covers the corporate risk
register from July 22
two and has set out in section 3.3 of
your covering report there's been one
risk where likelihood has increased are
one failure to say to God children and
vulnerable adults and there's two risks
where likelihood has decreased which is
R3 failure to Target services and
influence Partners effectively to
support identified housing needs of
increasing aging population and r29
failure to deliver Services as a result
of kobit 19.
members are presented a full corporate
risk register for Quarter Two at
appendix a and they're asked to review
and comment to present challenge where
corporate goals might not be met
thank you does anybody else any other
officer want to um present on here or
say anything Mr Gala do you because I
think there's something on here that you
you may wish to speak on or do you want
to wait for questions
perhaps go through just a short Preamble
because that might help to answer some
questions and concerns thank you I think
that's an excellent idea
and it's just really to absolutely
trying my best to reassure members the
safeguarding risk increase related forum
and the attendance of the Forum is a
preemptive increase it's not as a result
of anything you're a case management or
failure to manage safeguarding reports
to the council
and mostly due to the various work
pressures for the designated
safeguarding officers now these are the
if you like the more trained officers in
safeguarding they sometimes struggle
upon to attend the Forum and there's
such attendance at that safeguarding
quarter which is an office of forum can
be in line
um so work has begun to basically update
the designated safeguardic war and
leaders to try and make it more concise
and more focused a smaller group but one
that can hopefully overcome the
attendance issues now once that's in
place I'll be bulleting the attendance
at the folks they've got it for just to
make sure it's back up to the levels
um now just to reach right this does not
mean the council is failing to act until
second percentage not we're absolutely
doing that and that case management
system is working great in that regard
you do need to do with the hook up we'll
tweaks around the edges
that's fine
um in terms of safeguarding discussions
um again they're happening on a officer
level basis in a robust effective manner
and really this this increase is just to
represent the fact that those
discussions are happening but perhaps
not in the form of the safeguarding
umbrella so that hopefully sets the
context okay thank you Mr Gayla
um members so the recommendations are
that members review the corporate risk
register in appendix one and provide
comments and feedback for consideration
little two that's members review
progress members review progress of this
corporate risk mitigation actions in
appendix 2 and provide comments and
feedback for consideration little three
that members are assured through this
review that corporate risk and it and it
should be corporate risk is being
managed effectively and four that
members challenge risk where the
committee feels that the council's
corporate goals may not be achieved
right so we'll do it again members Page
by Page
51.
52
cancel login
just pleased to see that the R7 that he
says in the Box I think because again I
can't see the control strength is good
because controls in place and considered
adequate to reduce the risk so I'm
pleased to see that we are doing the
things that we're doing to try and
manage these risk and to get a greater
result
okay members 53
I'm not going too fast on my members no
59
.
60 uh jump 50 well you're 59 60 cancer
stilts Please Mr Gala I think this is
going to be you so stand by your bed
thank you madam chair um I'm
disappointed that a lot of these at-risk
ones have been on here when I was the
chair and they don't seem to have
changed to this group
um I am a bit worried about R1 and R2
and I can understand what Mr Geller has
said
um
I believe that R1 which is the
safeguarding also has popped up in our
audit system with our policies can Mr
Geller please assure me that these
policies for safeguarding are now in
place and I do wonder whether we should
recommend that this safeguarding is put
forward to uh overview and scrutiny to
go through because safeguarding has been
at risk on a lot of our policies
including our as I say audit reports as
well thank you cancer steals Ms Gala
okay so in terms of um
let's say Colleen was being on there
long term I would say that that might be
coffee to do with uh my my
issue with not adjusting the
likelihood that didn't come apart until
uh then you should have seen the risk at
all I do believe the safeguarding
processes and policies that we've got in
place of robust we do have safeguarding
policy they're in place and active if
members want access to that I
members in the right direction in terms
of carrying out an additional overview
through the ons I absolutely would
support that because I appreciate that
God is very important anything I can do
to show up in that process I've got them
um Mr Dodson please
so I will come what Mr Gayla said in in
terms of
you know the the overview and scrutiny
because it's such an important issue it
is such an important issue though that
it's my understanding of belief that
that will always be on the corporate
risk register we're never going to
eliminate the risk from that and it
would be remiss of us to try to it
should always be there so that so that
it's reviewed and that the risk has that
that level of
um priority within the organization
thank you Mr Holmes and also obviously
to highlight what Mr Killer said he he
increased that risk so I hope that
evidence is that officers are reviewing
and and will bring things forward
um so you know he's deliberately
increased that risk to bring it to your
attention but obviously telling you how
that's going to be mitigated so
hopefully that will come back down again
but I I agree with everything's being
said we can review I don't think it'll
ever be off this list simply because
it's such an important issue
um cancer still
I don't think as you say that it should
go off a list at all but I would like to
see it
um that it's a bit lower in the risk
because I believe it on order it was in
the red
um and also that we do have the staff I
think that that's one of the things that
worries me is we're actually saying here
that we haven't got the staff
for this and and that was one of the
reasons why I said maybe overview in
scrutiny need to just go through it with
officers to make sure that we are on on
top of uh safeguard
Mr Holmes do we have the staff uh we do
have the staff and I think um there's no
specific safeguarding team or
safeguarding staff they're made of
offices of the council
um most of our experience and expertise
is on our Frontline staff our housing
team for example deal with safeguarding
issues complex safeguarding issues every
single day so there are a number of
staff that are engaged in safeguarding
and the skill has mentioned the the
designated reporting officers so they
they are made up from teams across the
council so and the difficulty has been
actually getting the time for them to be
able to meet and discuss as a forum so
um please don't think there aren't staff
to do so guarding is everybody's job to
do safeguarding and there's a form of
council offices which we are trying to
sharpen up and get them more time to
meet
um and that's the essential issue so
this is sort of runs through everything
we do and all of our services really
made wanted to prepare The Proposal did
you want to do I posted that it would it
would too over in scrutiny because
that's that as a recommend I might need
to take some advice here um Mr Dunson do
we add that on as the recommendation or
do we put that as a separate proposal
do you know
I believe it can be added as a
recommendation yeah a recommendation for
referral to ons yeah
um is that all right Berner would you
like to um listen to what cancer stilts
is going to say and we will We would
like to add the five please to the
recommendations and
um cancer stilts could you just read it
well I think it's pretty basic but I
would just like to recommend that we put
the safeguarding of
um children and vulnerable adults to ons
um just to investigate to make sure that
we are on top of everything and
supporting Mr Geller in in the work yeah
so so did you get that
okay well I'm going to come back to you
to read it out when I read them out
again okay page six uh we've done page
16 page 61 members
62.
6
D3 then now this is appendix two members
page 63 is there anything on 63 appendix
2
and finally page 64 appendix 2. okay
excellent let's go back to the
recommendations that members review the
corporate risk register in appendix one
and provide comment and feedback for
consideration that members review
progress progress I said it again I do
apologize of the corporate risk
mitigation actions in appendix 2 and
provide comment and feedback for
consideration three that members are
assured through this review that
corporate risk and is is being managed
effectively for that members challenge
risk where the committee feels that the
council's corporate goals are not being
achieved and five that the safeguarding
of children at adults Berna can you read
the rest for me that
safeguarding of children and vulnerable
adults is referred to overview and
scrutiny furry view to ensure that we
are supporting this area of work
together with the officers undertaking
this work excellent thank you very much
burner members I so proposed do I have a
second though
um yep uh cancer Thompson and just
before I go to the vote councilor um
Logan would like to speak before I vote
Council again thank you that's only
short one and it's um it's actually nine
with what the recommendations are which
I fully support if I was able to vote
um I'd like to look um or I'd recommend
to the committee that you look at the
risk assessment methodology that you use
because the way that the risk
assessments are calculated
um there's two there's different methods
to do it there's quantitative and
quantitative so there's more depth that
you could look at to extrapolate your
risks so it's something to say I'm sure
Mr Geller's got that and I think
with your new HSE you've got a new
health and safety person starting that
would be a really positive thing for you
to look at because risk assessments can
be very subjective and looking at the
methodology that you use you would get a
better objective might not get a
different outcome but you'd have more
detail in that so okay it's just homes
would you yeah I think Mrs Hughes will
look at look at the format of that and
we can review that and you're absolutely
right we do have a new health and safety
risk officer started with the council um
obviously this this risk assessment is
for a slightly different purpose but I'm
sure we can take this away and review
the methodology and see if there's any
improvements to it thank you and thank
you give your contribution Council Lagan
right members let's progress I've got a
proposed a second to agree by scent
please all those recommendations
thank you
excellent uh
gender item nine annual governance
actions update Pages 65 to 68. misuse do
you want to present the final report
please
um so since the revised format in 2020
each year our annual governance our
governance arrangements and also
identifies further best practices
following year
table 3.5 of the report shows the full
list of identified actions in the 2122
report those highlighted in Gray have
previous ly reported to the committee as
complete
a further affection around staff process
Improvement training has moved to
completion in this reporting schedule
commentary updates are also given for
the open actions for member review of
progress and challenge
sorry
okay thank you the recommendation
members is that the committee reviews
the annual governance statements table
and updates below any challenges where
necessary
members don't have any questions
councilor fluke and then councilor
Thompson please thank you chairman um
page 66 the um
I appreciate it it's it's the second one
down or the first one actually
um which which starts off build on
member officer code on that training
um
yeah I think that I I appreciate why
it's in there and I appreciate why it's
not in Gray but I think it's been
demonstrated recently particularly with
the
um planning policy working group and and
the um
the corporate projects working group how
important it is to have face-to-face
meetings and I think that after the last
council meeting I had quite a long
discussion with Mr Butcher and I'm
delighted that he's given us an option
of face-to-face meetings because I think
it's easier for members to interact with
officers particularly when there may be
opposing views in a face-to-face
scenario rather than than by teams or
some other means and it it's quite
interesting over the last 18 months I've
spent a lot of time at pricewater houses
headquarters in Canary Wharf and over
that 18-month period the amount of staff
that are now back in the offices working
face to face and their number one policy
now is to work with their customers face
to face as well but I do think with some
of these you know more I won't say
controversial but certainly where
officer members do have opposing views
it works well and it and it helps to
understand you know both members and
officers understand each other's foibles
um so I really do think that we should
go back to that and as far as the
commentary is concerned on a lighter
subject when I first joined this
um uh when I first joined the council
there was a suggestion that words were
implanted into reports to
um for members to spot to ensure that
they'd read the report and you found one
haven't you and I I'd never seen the
word gnu in there
but uh yeah so it is a new online
registration perhaps someone's going to
say that's an acronym or something but I
don't think it is but the point I did
make about you know officer members
meeting face to face and certainly
hybrid meetings for working group I've
seen it pay dividends twice now and I
really do think that we should consider
this for the next administrative year or
Municipal year
I totally agree and I think Mr dad knows
my view on wanting to face to face
especially with this committee obviously
which I share
um
yeah and it did but thank you for that I
totally agree with that and hopefully we
will be able to look at doing that and
just before um I come to you cancer
stilts
um 3.3 Miss Hughes and I know you've
tried to help me on this but I wondered
if any of the members have got an issue
and it says action plan is held on our
SharePoint I still can't get into
SharePoint I've been that you tried to
log in and it says you you can't have
access and then you sent me an email and
I still couldn't get in so I don't know
if any other members are successful in
getting into SharePoint but uh
can anybody or is it just me
no so I'm struggling to to access that I
don't know if that can be would you like
me to put a fresh serve ticket in or
could could you try and sort that out
for members because it's obviously not
just me
thank you I um
I appreciate that everybody
yeah
um cats sorry cancer Thompson I do
apologize
thank you Jim
um
um I'm actually at the bottom of page 65
it's the first item in the table about
the ldp review
um just like a bit of clarity please if
possible on which staff of where um with
policy and DM and um is there an impact
on the ldp and its policies that we
wouldn't be having anyway
um
explanation would be very helpful thank
you thank you Council Thompson I think
it's an excellent question it came up at
a meeting the other day
um Mr Dodson
I think that's for you
yes sorry I
caught most of that question so I'll
just paraphrase just to to check my
understand the question was around the
the the policy officers and the The
Joint work that that's happening with DM
in some areas and whether that's an
impact on on resources
yeah
um yes there has been some some joint
work in and I think you know as
as a corporate leadership team we need
to look at the always manage the the
pressures of the organization and look
at where the the key pressures are
um there there have been some
um acute pressures in the development
management area and um clearly
um colleague
um Mr Holmes has brought forward a plan
around that that to address those but it
has been necessary in the the short term
to shuffle our resources to make sure
that we're we're meeting those needs
um it isn't impacting greatly on the the
the the the planning policy the work
that's that's been going on through the
the ldp review and the The Five-Year
housing land Supply work is is
continuing um to progress and all of the
the studies in the background that were
scheduled to still continuing to go on
um within the dodp process as well
um so as well as the a12 so that there's
so much go get going on but um but but
yes it's there is a an overlap and there
is work going on and clearly the the
proposals that were supported through
Council
um last week in terms of bringing the
the planning policy and DM back together
as a single unit will mean that that
works in a much more integrated way in
the future in any case
thank you
Cassie Thompson
Mr Holmes do you want to add
and and to offer a bit more reassurance
obviously we've been able to fill some
of our vacancies now through contractors
obviously some budget was made available
for us so our dependency I guess around
the policy team is is still there but um
you know slightly less than it was and
probably will become even more
um less reliant on them but um hopefully
that will all improve the situation
um thank you thank you thank you
thank you we're not querying what's
happening I just want to make sure I
understand yeah okay
um I have a question what is the review
via the planning policy project board
what's the planning apology project
board who's it made up of
please
does anybody know sounds a very Grand
title is there any members on it or is
it uh just offices
please the the project board is an
officer
um but I I've I've not got the reference
to to to to where you've picked that up
up from oh sorry it's on page 66 Mr
Dodson and it's um the top box and it is
one two three four six lines down from
the bottom sorry no no that's useful
because the the the planning policy
project board is the the officer board
that obviously the there's the advantage
Advisory Group which is members the
working group that the project board is
more operational sitting under that
making sure that that sort of lower
level of of um of um
project decisions are made there at a
resource level
Etc so I'm just looking for the context
to understand
exactly
the context of that
I think it just does it tie in with
members that's I mean I when I read that
I just it just stood out for me I
thought I didn't understand what it what
it was for
I I think I think all that it's it's
saying there is that um
the the ODP review through that that
project board make sure it takes account
of the corporate plan the climate action
strategy building those climate actions
in and the commercial strategy making
sure that corporately there's a
consistency between the policies in the
various areas tying it all together then
okay that's that's fine and members any
other questions uh cancer stilts please
yeah just a question for Clarity on page
67 it's talking about field engagement
and information sharing with parish
councils is this going to be done
through the Parish Clerk Forum which I
believe the chair of this committee sits
on
um or is that going to be done in a
different way
Mr Dodson do you know that
oh is that Mr Holmes
I've never I've never actually been
invited to a meeting I've never attended
a meeting in my capacity as the chair
so uh Mr Holmes uh there's some work
actually being looked at with the parish
locks Forum at the moment and I
understand we'll be looking to sort of
revisit that and also involve Parish
Council chairs as well so I think um
Josh is looking at that and pulling that
together as a project really so I think
we'll see a better level of Engagement
and some more frequent engagement so I
think that that piece of work we only
discussed it earlier this week so I'm
confident that'll come forward I thought
we'd try to do this over the years many
many times I thought um it been reviewed
how best to contact the parish and town
councils from the district yeah there
has been um Josh has been doing a bit of
a service it's actually been out
speaking to the parishes and I think
they've given him some feedback really
and you do that through the existing
Parish clerks forum and I think some of
that was about more timely information
share a bit more interactive so he's
building that around that sort of
feedback he's got and my understanding
is that that will be the intent he's
going to call together a meeting for
that proposal and then sort of set a
series of meetings going forward so
that's sort of all in hand as we speak I
think one of the areas that you need to
be sorry cancer stilts I'll come back to
you and just don't send them on a Friday
afternoon because everybody a lot of
Clerks don't work on a Friday and
they're usually Going Home by one
o'clock so any information needs to be
sent out on the Thursday or the
beginning of the following week even
though hopefully it's not out of date
and because a lot of things I now get it
as an Essex County councilor you um it's
too late there's no point and cancer
stills yeah I was just going to come
back to uh Mr hums if I remember rightly
um the Town Council used to have
meetings with
um The District Council and councilors
um once a year I think it was and
they've all stopped and I don't think
there have been any meetings
you know
uh General can confirm we do meet with
the Town Council corporate leadership
team meets with the Town Council and
probably quarterly basis and I think the
last meeting that the leader also met
with the town mayor so we've upped the
engagement directly with the Malden Town
Council we'll be exploring Burnham Town
Council
um as part of this work that Josh is
doing so so there is um there is that
liaison going on
what about other councils
outside Malden
German that's exactly exactly the point
as I mentioned we have a dialogue with
modern Town Council and we need to make
sure it's Equitable and obviously and
that is why Josh is working on this sort
of way that we can actually engage right
across the district with all the town
and Parish councils and make that to be
sort of the Forum that we take forward
so that's the sort of position we're at
right now thank you obviously there is a
serious side to it because we do go and
get moaned out don't we I'm sure Council
bluffer gets moaneda as well that we we
don't have the same that's fully
understood okay right so I can see that
members are getting bored now so we're
going to actually put the recommendation
forward again
um that the committee reviews the annual
governance statement table and updates
below the challenges where necessary can
I have a second to please
councilor Fleming members greed by
Ascent that's great thank you right any
other
urgent Tysons of business the chairman
decides none members thank you for your
contribute contributions this evening I
now draw the meeting to a close at oh
what is it nine is that I can't got the
wrong glasses 18. thank you 9 18 p.m as
the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter any further
discussion and please leave the meeting
via the exit door behind the top table
bearing in mind social distancing thank
you thank you members a closer meeting
thank you officers
well done